okay thank you we're gonna start the
word the light up they have to do Rico
talk there will be a reception right
after so this is joint work with Antonia
Morales and Joon sang Tonio's from tama
and also me c9 sicily from nanjing audit
who also had two representative on
fajitas very well represented today
here they are antonio in june so i want
to talk about the problem of this
creature location there will be a set of
agents and will be a set of goods and
we're going to assign the goods to the
agents that goods are going to be in the
visible exercise will be to try to
understand how to do this in a way that
is fair in a model which there are
endowments so these agents are going to
start out with some sort of property
rights or endowments over these codes
why endowments well endowments i think
are relevant for any kind of allocation
problem where we don't start from
scratch
imagine we reallocate we enter situation
we're going to do some market design be
some objective but you know people have
already already our people in this
environment and so you know to get them
to buy into the market design we need to
you know guarantee that they are not
going to be worse off by the think about
so next week we're going to reallocate
the offices here in simons we already
have offices here you know maybe we'd
like to once we have we don't want to
end up something worse but we might be
willing to change you know maybe one of
us likes to be closer to that what a
coffee is maybe others try to be closer
so I was the corner office in this city
medical building the the other the other
pitch I want to make is for school
choice so school choice as you know I'm
sure everyone here knows is you should
be model with the school's property
rights or capture by by priorities and I
claim that this is not necessarily the
way you want to do things so as property
rights priorities or equivocal and
they're not transparent because you know
just because you have a high priority in
a particular school doesn't mean that
you're guaranteed to get into the school
that depends on the detail of the whole
market depends on what everyone else's
priorities are and it depends on what
everyone else does so in that sense
priorities as a way of ensuring property
right is not necessarily the best model
endowments are very explicit property
rights so I can endow you with a seat at
a neighborhood school I can endow you
with a seat at a school with your
sibling goals or some diversity
objectives you can Dowe everyone with a
chance of going to the very best schools
so it's very easy and very transparent
to capture these things with them
endowments so anyway you don't need to
be convinced by this to you know to
further results in in our paper but it's
I think one reason why why we might want
to think about endowments in these types
of programs so what do we do in this
paper well dealing with endowments
creates interesting conceptual and
technical issues conceptual issues
because they make aliens unequal and
that creates a conflict between onv and
property rights let me explain what I
mean
so if you have equal agents is easy to
be fair right seems to understand how to
treat they want the same thing you flip
a coin but what about unequal agents
it's generally impossible
to be fair to unequal agents without
violating property rights
imagine someone here has the corner
office right and we all want a corner
office and the first thing to do would
be to flip a coin or many coins to see
who gets the corner office but not
necessarily inviting involves making the
current owner of the corner office worse
off so generally speaking just applying
no no Envy as our notion of fairness is
going to be problematic so how can you
be fair when agents are unequally
endowed that's that's in a sense the the
point of this paper so I need to give
you the models so we're gonna propose a
notion of fairness for an equally
endowed agents we've proved that it can
be achieved together with efficiency and
individual rationality by the way this
is another reason to like this model
over the standard school choice model
because in the standard school just know
there's a conflict between efficiency
and fairness it won't be there will not
be such a conflict here you will be able
to achieve both efficiency and fairness
moreover you cannot obtain our ultimate
and market outcome so explain how it
will be related to here in sac how
certain type of it is and moreover you
can achieve this in a framework which is
along the line so what fajita was
suggesting in his paper we have
constraints so you may want to design a
impose some constraints on the
assignment program to satisfy some
policy objectives and I'm gonna show you
that with fairly general constraints can
be accommodated in this setting all
right I'm gonna skip the literature just
very quickly mention the notion of
fairness I'm gonna give you has already
not the same but the same spirit has
been proposed by yield mats but he uses
Cetina in a different model the results
are not connected anyway so fairness the
other thing I want to say before I write
on the model is I'm gonna use fractional
assignments because I the only way you
can tell
can't sleep a coin so here's the model
there will be a set of agents I and
agents set of objects s with L object a
lottery is going to be an elevation
element of this set so this is
everything that is below the simplex so
all the vectors in RL plus which add up
to less than one the idea implicit in
this definition is that it are really L
plus one object this one additional
object which is selected outside option
so if we don't get an object we get that
and whenever this sum is less than one
then the complement is the it's the
probability of getting this outside each
agent will have a utility function which
are assumed throughout this continuous a
monotone that assign utility number to
each lot I'm going to put some
assumptions on you later on but for now
it's a think of this as our any
functions continue zamana to again the
implicit assumption here monotonicity is
that the outside option is the worst
thing that's not a city you want one of
these goods okay which one you want
leather pants but but you like these
Goods more than the outside option okay
that's the model
so you may have risk aversion so this
preference so one assumption I'm going
to use is it cost concavity so that's
an allocation will be an assignment of a
lottery to each agent so that when I add
up for each agent overall the object it
has some capacity reaches some capacity
queue but actually I'm just going to
work with a capacity of one and this is
without loss of generality because you
can just include many copies of the same
object okay and you can't be indifferent
here that there won't be an assumption
about strict references so you can just
have as many copies as supporters so
think of each object as being as
existing as in a supply one that's an
allocation and allocation has to be a
specification of a lottery for each
agent so sure we exhaust other capacity
what's envy well envy is that in an in
an assignment in allocation X I am
this.j if I will be better off getting
with J god
we know and it's very easy to get okay
just give everyone an equal chance of
everything but of course it's possible
that one likes you know more about two
hands and two legs more but one has and
so you would like to him
chances for mutually beneficial trades
they won't allow for those things so we
want to allow for those things to the
extent of the exhaust all the possible
gains from trade so what we want is a
Pareto optimal location occasions Pareto
optimal if this other allocation Y which
is at least as cause for every agent as
efficiency and parity can we obtain it
yes we can some old result by hidden
sector which says there is a Pareto
optimal and we fear location and it's a
marketing advantage so I will give you a
precise statement of the theorem in two
slides
his definition of equilibrium in
Hellenistic culture equilibrium is a
pair an X and a P in which X X is
allotted a for each agent and P is a
price for each object such that the sum
of the XS equal to 1 so it's an
allocation think of this as demand
equals supply each X I has to solve the
optimization problem for each agent so
they have to be buying the best thing
that they can afford given that they're
constrained to choosing something in the
sub simplex and that they are given an
income of one even $1 and they can spend
more than that so income is independent
of prices in the under no endowments in
this model it's no we are talking about
the dog
so what I want you to realize this is
not so I was talking so we talked about
markets this is what's called a pseudo
market because it's not this is not a
closed model so here the the money comes
from somewhere else so you can set up
this market if you're a market a signer
but it's not this is not a good model a
model of an economy well region law they
would not do this because it's that well
you can give Larry :
yes if you if you give everyone the SMN
Talmud it would be all right
so fairness an efficiency can be
achieved as long as we have some
disappeared on the utilities you don't
need this much but certainly if duties
are linear then you can obtain both the
freeness imperative humanity through so
let's imagine that we wanna try to build
on this idea to allow for endowments so
now I'm going to augment the model by by
giving each agent an endowment what's an
endowment an endowment is an initial
lottery that I give each agent and
notice here I don't have a miner
sub-index here so this is the actual
simplex so Omegas they add up to 1 yes
so you have Pareto efficiency yep and
briefly you also have some kind of
incentive compatibility because you have
a large market and no I'm not going to
be talking about large no today today
today I'm not going to talk about it now
but but yes so these markets the large
version of this
approximate education question so are
you requiring that everybody is assigned
absolutely 105 I'm not requiring that
but I will assume that the number of
objects and agents is the same so that
will be true so there are so you can
write down this is not important for the
result but you just need to make sure
that that you allow for excess supply if
there are more objects and so write down
a version of the colibri mean which this
exact market-clearing so that so that
that that about that yeah that's a good
question
I think if you're not owned by someone
you can just share them equally and then
repeat this procedure and yeah the point
I mentioned earlier you can imagine the
many things you can do with the end so
the model then is agents or objects each
agent is described by utility function
and an endowment vector and I'm gonna
start by dealing out all the endowment
either the pendulum and is gonna be
distributed among all the agents ok very
good
so now how do we build on healing sick
Houser to account for endowments we'll
do an issue property rights so we want
to make sure that people you know we
can't give everyone now $1 because you
know whoever got the corner office is
very variable in government and I we put
them down and down to $1 now this person
I don't be able to buy so to make sure
that we preserve this property rights we
need to somehow capture the Indian
dollars this is a very classical way of
doing this which is operational Ibrahim
so we should given this model is
apparent X and a P where the X is
allotted for each agent the priests and
non-negative price factor like was
demand now the change is that the supply
has been distributed among all the agent
but the aggregate supplies today see
each X I saw the problem of choosing
consumption bundle that I optimally a
lottery optimally that they can afford
and they the change within psych Hauser
is that now the income is endogenous it
depends on us
take down it for me it's in the - yes it
will force yes it is in in the solution
this this relaxation will the thing is
there are economists in which all the
agencies et functions are expected today
so there are linear that have normal
recycle over this observation is not
huge it's already in here anyhow so this
won't allow us to get started
now I if I have time
yeah 20
okay let me just quickly show you the
example because if you haven't seen it
it's really worth saying it's just
extremely simple example very
indestructible so what you need to
understand that budget sets or not the
way we are used to thinking about right
so so if you open up muscular Western
and green you will see that you have an
endowment you have prices you can afford
everything in the green set why because
you can sell your endowment that price
is P and you can buy it back so you can
certainly afford your endowment and
whatever it exhaust your income so the
the budget line must pass through the
endowment and you can afford Elgin is
cheaper now in addition there is the
simplex constraint so really your
budgets it becomes this set here okay
look at this and say well that's not so
bad
I'm it's very nice it's no longer the
time I'm used to but it's still you know
convex and compact I'm sure can work
with this turns out you can't and and
here's here's an example this was your
one with your line WI going through the
VIII yeah it's the simplex so this is
the simplex this is the sub simplex and
in addition you have the budget line so
this is what you can afford
so here's the example so example has
three agents and two objects but they're
two copies of the second object okay
these are the utility functions they are
linear so if I get a probability one of
object a I get ten if I'm agent one same
thing if I'm agent - but only one if I'm
agent three if I get object B or it's
copy I get one if I'm agent one one if
I'm agent 2 and 10 if I'm agent 3 and
the endowments are uniform so 1/3 1/3
1/3 okay I just slept together the two
copies of object B
if you look at this you think about a
little bit there's an obvious way of two
copies of object B and agent three we
realize so let's give one copy to this
agent and then let's split equally 50/50
chance of getting object a between one
and two then the remaining 50/50 object
so the obvious location now let's try to
support this as a valuation equilibrium
what would we need to do well use the
simplex and here's the obvious
allocation we want agents 1 & 2 to get
the 50/50 allocation the 50 assignment I
want the third agent to get a
probability 1 of object P endowment is
1/3 2/3 so I now I need to I know what
the location is and it's gonna be prices
that's that support it do you see what
the problem is
no matter which prices I get I need to
get any these guys need to buy this one
this guy needs to buy that one no matter
which prices I get it's really the only
price is going to work is the one that
has the same price for both I do that
then these guys are gonna buy here I
would have excess demand for object so
there's no way up and so there are no
variation even in this model
particularly simple and striking example
which it's not so what is the lira mean
when there is a fixed income of $1 right
Highland enjoy just showed that yeah
because when this but yeah I'm very high
level idea is no because because the
prices here have in this model the
prices don't have any nominal meaning
hidden sec how's that they have nominal
meaning so here they so the usual
existence proof relies a lot on being
able to make Goods arbitrarily expensive
so that you cannot buy them and if any
sorry and if you make them or batali
cheap you cannot buy a lot lots of them
because of the bound on the on
consumption space you can't get excess
demand to blow up when you need to
so this example our energy
yes a Monday the early part the same
thing because because the prices in the
heuristic house are the prices don't
affect your income no no I think you
whatever you take the equilibrium from
for the one dollar case and then scale
the prices to like whatever like it's a
free dollar I kill the plans to be equal
to yeah this this is an equilibrium in
the hyunsik house' model with supported
by prices to zero
yeah so what is to make them 3-0 where
does it pass you you what you want is
that the budget comes here for that you
need an an exogenous nominal income
[Music]
something like that yeah you can do
things like that yeah so we have another
paper in which I give you just a little
bit of AB nominal income in addition to
this and then you can get existence
anyway I don't know but this is not my
examples here in the house and then talk
to you later about it anyway not only do
you get non-existence the first well
first theorem fails there are Pareto
ranked well reached an equilibrium so so
many things go wrong so what do we do so
try to deal with this in a different way
so here's the just a very quick
definitions these are extremely standard
definitions so utility functions you or
concave if they're concave quasi concave
if the cost concave so upper control
sets or convex sets expected utility if
they're linear the only definition you
might not have seen is see my strictly
cost concave and what that says is that
if if you have X is greater than you
have said then all along the line
segment between X and said it's
I want to say I don't wanna work with
strictly Kosygin cake because then I
rule out expert utility expect utility
is semester
it's a war the semi strictly is X is
better than Z then any convex
combination is also better than sitting
straight all right more standard
definitions X is weak Pareto optimum and
it's this medication Y which is strictly
better for everyone
it's epsilon weak Pareto optimal if
there's no location would just better
buy property rights so you haven't
thought much about property right before
let me just mention what this means in
allocation X is acceptable to I if what
I get it's not worse than eyes endowment
property right means that I have the
right to consume my endowment you can't
give me something that's worse for me
than what I would get if I just consume
whether it's rational if it is accepted
to all the agents
very good now this is our definition of
fairness so this is how we accommodate
fairness in the presence of
and so remember I Envy's j @x if i would
like to get or J so we know we gonna so
like I mention before we will be able to
eliminate envió together because doing
that will involve violating property
rights so what we will do is will try to
eliminate MV to the extent that we don't
violate property specifically the
definition that I'll talk about today is
that I am this J will sometimes be
tolerated and you tolerate only if in
some says Jason dormant is good enough
most specifically if J regards X I as
unacceptable
okay so imagine I so I'm the mechanism
designer yes I comes complaints to me
and said look you're being unfair why
did you give Jada's I would like to get
what Jay got so my reply to that would
be I'm sorry if I were to give Jay what
I got what I gave you then it will be
violating Jay's property rights so think
of the of the swap between I and J as a
remedy 20 this is that certain remedies
or not viable which ones are not viable
the ones that buy that involve violating
Jai's property rights
now you might say why do you only
consider these pairwise swaps as
remedies I think they make sense they're
natural no you think of some realistic
complainant my - it makes sense it's the
kind of idea in the school choice
literature when you talk about justify
Dembe is I and this J and you can J's
priority in the school but actually the
tools that we use can accommodate much
more general sorts of remedies paper if
you want to come up with a more
elaborate reassignment that satisfies
eyes envy there are many much more
general version that you can do and if
you want at the end of the talk I can
tell you why is it because it's because
it's Jay's property rights
so I have to use Jays property
disciplines
because the question about Jays property
rights is whether Jay likes X I as much
as but they may not be the one who is
assigned XJ sorry yeah it is
so XJ person Jay may be assigned another
office in the at add the location X I am
this J meaning I would like to get what
J got I have to learn her office as my
endowment you give me the penthouse
right
Kathir you know you know somebody has
wants the penthouse yes yes okay yes so
you're talking about non pairwise swaps
so when we are list - the corner office
my allocation is the penthouse and you
envy the penthouse you would rather have
the penthouse and whatever you got right
and then you tell me yeah but he has the
corner office I'm like what does a
courthouse
to do with me in the house so so I have
something and I'm talking about swapping
what I have with the prism and envy
they're really bad come it's XJ same as
WG no I said you got them very small
office so if you do this one
he will get instead of the penthouse the
very small office which is worse than
the corner office which is no but it's
not only because if you have the squat
it was not very to efficient I think
there is more than so I will get patty
to efficiency as well so swaps that a
mutually-beneficial will not happen
anyway so if in the swap you know you
know in a swap you know J with how to
get something worse so what but but I'm
I'm not talking about mutually benefits
of trades I'm talking about where the
swoop violates this other person's
property rights
anyhow doesn't benefit J does benefit me
J doesn't have property rights to XJ J
only has property rights to Omega J
anyway so I think that an example with a
penthouse on there so let's talk about
it later okay but but you saying like
I'm not gonna have an exogenous notion
for what is better or worse to determine
what's well I'm gonna allow the agents
subjective utility to tell me what's
better for them announcer yes yeah yeah
there is an objective way of doing with
the equilibrium prices all right so the
contrapositive eye has justified them be
towards J if I am this J and J could
take what I got without violating J's
property rights this we don't want I
want to rule out this kind of ending
of course this can be translated into a
property of the location in the
allocation this is not justify them is
no agent has justified
so now there are this it was quickly but
then there are these little technicality
in the proof forces me to do some
approximations so that requires these
twists on the notion not justify that I
have no strong justified ending if I am
this J and J would strictly regard X I
as pedometer and epsilon positive I ask
epsilon justified envy towards J if J
and the J likes X I by Omega
so hips and justify then be implies not
justify them which implies not strong
justify so is the first theorem if you
do the first are concave and the
existent allocation that satisfies this
property its Epsilon
maybe the rational epsilon parrot doctor
has not absent ratified and taking the
options to zero this one which is
individual irrational wheatbelt optimal
has no strong justified or over if the
two functions are expected utility we
can do a totally different kind of I
will show you the proof of this tool
this at least the main idea behind it
this is proving a completely different
way but if the expect utility this one
with this I or parent optimal okay no
not we put it off now which is which is
a big deal here and has no strong
justified requires expected so could you
walk me through how this applies to the
example you've had before because that
was an example of non-existence and this
is something awkward racionais gonna be
so the location I show you would satisfy
these properties in the so in particular
would pick out the 1/2 1/2 0 1
allocation
okay the next maybe okay the next the
second result that we have that we
really like is is the following so
suppose you did the functions are quasi
concave and that the Spade suit
condition so give me a few minutes and
tell you what this is I don't want you
to pay attention to this you see it's
not complicated but it's just annoying
then there exist continuous functions mi
these continuous functions are income
functions remember in the well raishin
model income is endogenous it depends on
prices it is very important because I
need to make sure that people get
something that is at least as good as
their endowment so they have to be able
to buy back their endowment so here I'm
going to construct these income
functions as dependent incomes in such a
way that I get the equilibrium condition
supply equals demand X is Pareto optimal
individual rational and has no justified
ending so it satisfies this desirable
properties and moreover each agent is
optimizing within the budget
well now the budgets are neither the
here in a sec how's the budget when
everyone gets $1 nor the the quality on
budget when communicates what you get
from biasing your endowment but the
income is specified by what income
function gives
so that the trick in this theorem is to
construct these income functions let's
do this job and they have to do to say
yes just man we have to do two three
things they have to ensure that we the
rationality always with the money I get
from this income function I can always
buy something at least as close my
endowment I always have enough money to
be at least as we low pass by it has to
ensure no justify that thing so the
construction is just something that if I
have time I'll show you where it is and
moreover it has to be such that you can
prove existence with it so for this
result we take the prices to line the
simplex well it does yes so you could
i'm fixing an economy here yes this is a
construction over your endowment
stoppable deficiency so we will swap but
you you will get something worse than
what you have now slowness it's not
worth that then would you turn your
endowment it's not justified why is this
different than just selecting the
particular point that you want maybe the
statement is not clear but yeah so given
the economy I construct the MS and then
with MS I prove existence or an
equilibrium that satisfies this so how
is this different from saying given the
economy like weight endowment for you
give it the economy I create a founder
XP and the dominance no no the endowment
so given the endowments are given before
so just well I convert there downloads
to money I generally have a function but
like it seems like the definition is
only using one point I mean first of all
it it is actually done in this way that
I said you define the whole income
function and then you prove existence or
equilibrium and the occlusion satisfies
these properties
yes anyway finally I want to make sure
that they can tell you a little bit
about so very very quickly if you
remember for heater stock there were
constraints for our model you can take
as primitive a set of allocations so in
the paper we also derive the these
constraint locations from more primitive
constraints but but you can take as
primitive allocations which is a convex
and compact set and it covers many
examples have been discussed in the
literature and you can just do all the
definitions modulo the constraints you
can prove the type of result I show you
the four subjects to constrain so you
get constrained efficiency you get
constrained in the rationality and
there's no strong equal type justified
then we were equal type means that you
know for hit on I or the same type if we
can always swap allocations without
violating constraints so for example if
the constraints are anonymous like in
the geographical distribution a
constraint that for hit on mentioned
earlier then everybody so the same time
you know just a quick comment on
constraint so let me just very quickly
tell you what the main idea behind the
proof of this theorem is measuring so
the way in which we proof is a prove it
is the following so we look at Italian
maximization problem well actually this
is not exactly how the proof works
because it's a little technical thing
that I mentioned before but big deal the
big idea is basically this one so in the
proof we have to do not proximation of
this but think of it this way so you
have you solve this utilitarian
maximization problem we want to choose
the weights on the utilities of the
agents in a fairway okay so to get a
fairer location so so this will
guarantee efficiency okay
but this basically with our anti
efficiency and then you want to be fair
so how you fare you choose fair welfare
weights you choose the lambdas here in a
fair way so how do you do it
so use the kkm lemma so let me tell you
what it is
okay km lemma says take the simplex the
simplex has in this case three vertices
then you take three sets one set for
this vertex one set for this vertex one
set for this vertex these sets are a
so-called kkm covering of the simplex if
each one is is toast and for any point
in the simplex that point you can think
of it as a probability distribution
among these three vertices very
pointless simplex look at the support
then the point has to be included in one
of the sets that corresponds to the
support so along this line the support
is this point and this point so any
point on this line must be either in the
blue set or in the green set on this
line either in the red set or in the
green set this line either in the blue
set or the red set in interior they they
can be in any one other points then kkm
says they must exist one point which is
you know three okay now these simplex is
what I'm gonna draw the lambdas from so
the blue set will be the set of all the
points where agent number one doesn't
envy anyone in a justice
the Green said were mm every MV new one
the red set were three dozen everyone
look at this point here we're given all
the way to agent one you'll be very
weird if agent one would envy someone
but all we care about this agent one you
got anything here I claim that must be
ID in the blue set or in the green set
so it must be either the one doesn't
envy anyone or two doesn't Envy anyone
now they could Envy each other but if
the end each other then you will get the
Perito then the efficiency would kick in
and the cost of maximizing this idiot an
objective I could improve the you treat
an objective so so they can't be M being
each other so at least one of them must
envy someone who receives zero weight in
the corresponding lambda letter that's
again very weird because if all I care
about are these two guys and I don't
care at all about this one is very
strange if I if I don't envy
so you improve that this cannot happen
okay and and they the endowments really
matter for this so this is the big idea
the KK the kkm lemma then delivers a
lambda welfare waits here which no one M
is anyone in unjustifiable the kkm lemma
is casino sperner's lemma and so it's a
fixed point type of ID it's not
algorithmic I'm sorry about that
and I'm gonna leave you with the Spade
suit condition which is a technical
condition has economic meaning but it's
technical because I can give you another
totally different condition which means
something totally different for the
economics of the problem which also does
the work and it's there to bridge the
gap between quasi equilibrium
equilibrium says something about the
behavior of the income close to the
boundary of the simplex
and that's why I set the epsilon sort of
wiggle room in the proof does that come
into play when you like by relaxing the
center optimizing over where does that
can you play it
elsewhere no the problem is that by
allowing zeros here you're not
guaranteed to get efficiency because of
the unit demand constraint so you need
to perturb this problem to guarantee to
get efficiency and when you perturb it
then you take the perturbation to zero
that's what the absence coming so when
you say the M eyes are like a function
because in your definition really used m
IFP right so I worry what you say it's
it's a function it we only care about
one people because they the Bolivian
comes with two things like yeah it's
it's the fine
I mean you you could s kept its M so
it's similar to here in Sec house and
[ __ ] ultimately I just care about
the allocation I set up the pseudo
market then I get an increment in the
pseudo market and then I get an
allocation ultimately implemented the
location the here and second it's
artificial thing so here this is exactly
the same thing just that the income
can't be one dollar the income is this
more complicated function of prices and
you let the market rather than an
equilibrium and then you with the
definition you say there exists P and so
it's only the MRI you have but I but
they did use the m2 find the P
yes it was you call a spade a spade
I find property rights a little bit of a
contentious notion and I'm curious to
what extent it's important here that the
like endowment or the property rights
somehow like what if I don't get to have
full claim to anything ever like you
know at some level some Society jointly
owns some portion of everything and
that's it's the application of sperner's
lemma somehow really requiring that my
endowment it's no allocations no it
becomes much easier that case yeah this
is only interesting if you care about
endowments well I mean but there are
many ways we can consider property right
like it doesn't have to be that I own
the corner office I could own like some
rights to the corner office but not
fully owned the rights
yeah I mean the physical endowments are
not important what is important is how
much utility or you guarantee to get how
happy I re so I am guaranteeing you that
you will be at least this happy and then
somebody says well buddy oh just rent I
just decide clean it's cuter and so he's
gonna get the penthouse and I say oh
this is very unfair and you say well he
thinks that yours is worse than what he
had initially so that means no no I just
think he should have no no no so the
condition is not that you that it's not
so the original owner of the penthouse
so I so the pentose my ex I the original
owner of the of the ex I see we saw the
deterministic so if the original excited
doesn't enter here so if you envy me the
question is would we be violating my
property rights if I were to get what
you got so take this is how I just told
you you get the penthouse so I am in
your penthouse an alternative assignment
would be
to give a corner office so it doesn't
buy you later it and I get the penthouse
and that doesn't mean it like that
maybe that view but there is an
alternative thing yeah this is because I
get to say why don't we randomly why did
he say that he could because he spirit
throw dice or something and then maybe
there's no Envy anymore you know what I
mean like the counterfactual you're
considering is only that you keep my
assignment versus me keeping yours and
I'm saying why would you consider other
company why don't you allow me to envy
you by me allowing to exchange not only
between you and honest and me but yeah I
mean so that we can do so actually you
can strengthen the notion you have Jay
you have K let's say now suppose that I
envies Jay okay and we're gonna say okay
we want to give this to I but what's j1
Vijay well maybe we violate chase
property rights if we give Jay eyes
but now suppose we're gonna give JK and
making better off as long as we don't
violate case yeah so so this is this if
you impose this is the this theorem is
is that yes
so in fact we only have the proof of
this in the paper and then it's easy to
see
[Applause]